the problem is I don't think that can
happen where everyone gets their first
choice because especially nowadays you
have 80 percent of women sleeping with
20 percent of guys so the five thinks
she's an eight because she's sleeping
with the eight nine or ten and so when
she gets married she's gonna view her
husband as less that's another issue
with um Sleeping with a lot of guys did
you know if you sleep with more than
five guys your chance of a happy
marriage after 10 years it goes from 80
to 25
casual sex why because because the more
men you sleep with it you lose your
ability to bond with each one pair
bonding yeah it's pair bonding so so if
you sleep with one guy you're gonna
compare the next guy to him if you sleep
with 10 guys you compare all 10 if you
sleep with 20 you compare all 20 and